[electric whizzing noise]
[happy smile from Cliff Stool]
Let me use a yard stick, to add and subtract.
Really I am going to use a meter stick, to add and subtract. But...
Let me talk to the Americans for a moment.
5 plus 4 is 9.
Watch this.
5...
...plus 12...
...is 17!
And...
...I can say "oh".
"7..."
"...plus..."
"...13 is 20!"
It adds and subtracts.
I'm not telling you anything new.
What about multiplying and dividing.
[sighs]
There we go to logarithms.
:O
Logarithms!
I can hear people say "Oh, I hate logarithms. I hate it! Oh oh oh oh!
Logarithms: common logs were created so that instead of multiplying big numbers.
751 times 982...
; ･`д･´
What you would do is you take the logarithm of 751,
add it to the logarithm of 982, to get the logarithm of...
...something else, the answer.
Look up the anti-log of that, the backwards log of that, to get the result.
So, instead of adding and subtracting numbers
on these 2 meter sticks.
If I replaced these with logarithmic sticks, I can multiply and divide.
So, I've got a pair of meter sticks where I've covered up a couple numbers with the log of that number
The logarithm of 2 is 0.301
So, I'm gonna cover up 0.301 with 2.
I'm gonna cover up 0.301 with 2.
Well, the logarithm of 3 happens to be 0.48, more or less.
Now cover that up.
Look at this!
Instead of being nice and linear like this!
All the numbers squeeze up over here!
That's the way logarithms work.
Big numbers!
Squash up over here.
In the real nice end, lazy out here.
Let's see what we've made here.
I know that I can add distances, lets try it now.
Here's the number 2, here's the number 2.
Oh, 2 times 2 is 4!
2...
...times 3 is 6.
3 times 3 is 9.
It's multiplying!
Brady, come on over here, check this out. Instead of having a ruler like this.
Notice how, it's a ruler like here. Here's 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 and over here is 10 if you really wanna push on it.
So here's the slide rule, and this scale over here. The D scale is the important one.
Oh, π is hiding. Woah hey, there's our friend π. But this one also has 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Let me throw these sticks away and I'm only gonna look at these 2 scales here. The C and the D scales.
Let's just look at those. Let's go one step further, let's use this cursor.
2 times 4 is 8.
Okay, no surprise there. In which [we] now go in-between numbers. Let's try something a little bit more cool.
2 times...
2.1, 2.2, 2.3, 2.4, 2.5, 2.6, 2.7, 2.8, 2.9, 3. Okay, let's say 2 times 2 and a half.
2 times 2.1, 2.2, 2.3, 2.4, 2.5. Look at that.
2 times 2.5 is... almost exactly 5!
Let's look at between 1 and 2, there's all these extra numbers.
1.5 is over here but they didn't write the 1!
A piece of tape.
1.1, 1.2, 1.3... 1.9, 2, 2.1... 2.8, 3.0
There's pi!
1.2 times 2 is...
2.1, 2.2, 2.3, 2.4! Okay, it works!
1.25
1.25 times π is...
3.92, about..
I'll give it just a smidgen, right in here to...
So, why do I even bother owning a calculator? Well...
This is nice, it's sits next to me. You know I can, when I sit in here in my desk.
I can multiply, using a calculator.
So...
Like everybody else, I'm fairly lazy.
Let's fix this up just a little bit better.
Here, like this over here.
Now, I don't need to reach up anymore.
I can just say "Oh."
[electric whizzing noise]
Now I have a electric slide rule.
So, when I want to multiply or divide.
Oh.
2.1 oh, let's just move it back over to here.
2 times 2 is 4. All done electrically.
But of course, I need to move the cursor too..
Let's multiply 8 times 4. Oh.
Oh, 8 times 4...
Is a little bit more, it looks like 32. It's ether 3.2 or 32. The decimal place, I don't care about.
I'm just concerned with the numbers.
[Whispering] Slide rules don't know about decimal places.
Here's
51, 52, 53, 54, 50~, 55.5 times....
[more electric whizzing noise]
3 to give, oh, 1.67~
Something like this.
The latest advance in slide rule technology.
Subtitles by Touka Szulc